OK.
Gonna check this trap here.
I see something moving in there.
What the hell's that?
Something's growling.
It's like this deep moo.
OK.
[screaming]
There's something in there.
I have a feeling I know
exactly what it is.
[grunting]
I think there's an
electric eel in there.
Right there.
You see that?
I got a slithering eel in there.
Electric eels can
produce a shocking jolt
of over 650 volts.
[screaming]
Aye, aye, aye.
It's just like
sticking your finger
right into a light socket.
It's an adaptation the
eels have for hunting prey,
navigating in murky
water, and self-defense.
OK, get out of there.
Look at that.
That is an electric eel.
Do you hear that?
That's crazy.
OK, come on.
Go back in the water.
They're very mysterious, very
ugly, but amazing animal.
Their whole bodies
are just full of fat,
like hardly any muscle at all.
And, yeah, as far
as eating them goes,
there are very few
tribes that eat them.
I have tried 'em myself.
They're just, like,
lard, goo, gelatin.
Yeah, it's not nice, not nice.
Thankfully, the eel isn't the
only fish caught in the trap.
The catfish is alive, but
it can't move because it's
been stunned by that eel.
Basically they were
trapped together.
Oh, man.
Big meaty fish.
[music playing]